there's little abdullah for remembers
about the town he was born in
jalalabad afghanistan
[Music]
abdul and his family fled when he was
just nine
but memories of what the taliban forced
on children don't fade we used to wear
turbans to go to school this was one of
the uniform part of the uniform
and i used to complain to my mom that
why do i have to wear this piece of
cloth over my head to go to school
and she wouldn't she wouldn't have an
answer for it
now a father with a child of his own
he's haunted by the events unfolding in
afghanistan
he wants help to save afghan children
facing a life of compulsion
forced to wear turbans
forced to flee their homes everything's
going coming down to the ground again i
mean at the end of the day the people
are suffering
again from all this war and bloodshed is
the afghans
and i don't know why like you know
the world community cannot hear our
voices i don't know what we need to do
in order to raise our voice
abdullah is still a student today
reading accountancy in manchester but
he's increasingly distracted by what he
sees happening in the country he left
behind i speak to family members in
general but they're really scared for
their lives and that makes us scared and
worried as well for them i mean fair
enough i live thousand miles away from
them here as a human being or as a
relative you know you're concerned for
their safety
[Music]
abdullah says he shoulders added
responsibility the duty to build a life
here
without forgetting the ones he left
behind sadia chowdhury sky news in
manchester